so a pipeline is basically a mechanism
for connecting the output of one program
directly conveniently into the input of
another program so that you can do in
effect two stages of processing just by
saying program 1 vertical bar that's the
pipeline symbol second program and what
that does is to start both programs and
take the output quietly from the first
one and stick it into the input of the
second one and then of course you can
have multiple of those before that the
way that people connected programs well
first I think they often didn't think of
connecting programs at all you thought
of each program is its own thing and it
would produce some output then C might
put a few numbers into it like punch
card whatever it would sort them you
take that output and then take that and
literally sneak in a quorum put backs in
the next program right yeah you do that
as it where manually I mean
UNIX had the idea of file redirection
which made that syntactically easy the
new invention was to say hey wait a
minute we could put an operator to do
that right in the shell to command an
and command-line interpreter and then
that made it a lot easier to do and it
also encouraged people to if the
mechanism wasn't clean already retrofit
cleanliness into the implementation I
think it is a new idea with UNIX as far
as I know I have somewhere in my
collection of historical documents a
page that Doug McIlroy wrote in 1964
saying what we want to do is a mechanism
for screwing programs to connecting
programs together just like screwing
pieces of garden hose together that's
the model and then I think it was
probably three or four years later and I
don't know how it came about but it just
got done and literally a very very short
period of time
so basically the pipe is a pipe bomb
you'd expect parking rules regarding
yeah and you just screw on another
length of garden hose if you want to do
further processing a garden hose doesn't
process in that same sense but it's a
pipeline in the sense that you see in
certain kinds of manufacturing processes
or something like that where there's
just stages of processing almost above
well the rats won't be massing programs
it just does anything for you
well first you don't have to write the
one big massive program you've got
existing smaller programs that may
already do parts of the job and having
smaller programs is better than having
massive programs so that's one thing
another is that it's possible that the
amount of data you're processing would
not fit if you stored it in a file if
you took the output of one program and
had to store it totally before you put
it into the next permit might not fit
because remember we're back in the days
when disks on these things had if you
were lucky a megabyte or two of data not
a gigabyte or a terabyte but a megabyte
and so you couldn't instantiate
necessarily the output of a program
before passing it on to the next program
so the pipeline never had to instantiate
the whole output yeah start yeah big
word for storing and um so that meant
that you could kind of just sneak things
through without having to do this along
the way so that would be another example
and then it was just keeping track of
the intermediate files could be a
nuisance cleaning up the mess afterwards
all of those things went away with the
pipeline mechanism where you just said
hey this is what I want to do this this
this in order and you won't result on
the end of it give me one result at the
end of it was that something I still use
today oh absolutely yeah no it's still
fundamental mechanism and you use it all
the time you don't even think about it
at this point it's just part of it it
took a while to get retrofitted I think
into let's say Windows what is absolute
integral part of any UNIX based system
has been since you know since the late
60s just by taking existing programs
tools like grep and WC and sort and
somewhere in there I could throw in awk
so if I wanted to do a slightly more
complicated kind of processing so all of
these things are using UNIX tools with
glued together and pipelines in ways
that were not thought of in the original
design and that's the critical
observation and that's the reason why
these little programs are often much
more useful than the hub very big
monolithic one which does whatever it
does but nothing else it's definitely an
instance of don't reinvent the wheel
other people have done a lot of useful
things for you
and the ingenuity and often a lot of fun
of just saying hey I don't have to do
anything here except glue together
things that somebody else did for me
already I'm not getting wrong into the
stick another cliche through the minute
but is this where libraries come from so
you could think of programs like grep
and WC and sort as in effect libraries
but libraries of programs that
standalone rather than libraries of code
which is linked more or less permanently
with other pieces of code so it's it's a
library mechanism but in some ways at a
higher level and the programs are really
independent of each other law number one
a robot may not injure a human being or
through inaction allow a human being to
come to harm law number two a robot must
obey orders given it by human beings
except with